I'm Michael nolles and I can guess what
products these woke companies are
selling in these woke commercials
because I am a brave and strong
beautiful
woman gay no I'm I'm not actually I'm a
man but the commercials are all focused
on Brave strong beautiful woman Hear Me
Roar raar and I as a brave strong
beautiful man will guess what products
they are selling this video is brought
to you by expressvpn more from them in
just a moment for now I will bring my
powers of prediction prognostication
and yeah basically just those two to the
commercials take it away the
riddle a father is about to bring his
son to a job interview applying for a
position at a large stock broker company
in the city just as they arrive at a
company's parking lot the sun's phone
rings he looks at his father who says go
ahead answer it it the caller is the
Trading Company CEO who says good luck
son you've got this the son ends the
call and once again looks at his father
who is still next to him in that car how
can you pause it for a second it's the
mom can you believe it it's the mom
she's the CEO which is weird but it's I
guess it's happened before it's a little
weird though you didn't even know you
sexist keep going keep
going they don't know cuz they hate
women call from the CEO misogynists uh
but it says good luck son but he was
next to him so it's not the
father I think it was probably an audio
recording of his father maybe he made B
these women totally demo tape like is
like he has two fathers could be the
answer could be homosexuals it's his
mother ah Oh that's oh that's so stupid
yes of
course I should have thought of that yes
the CEO is a woman so I'm I'm
biased in a sense is this about
diversity and
inclusion I love this guy ah you got me
is this about
Dei okay yeah I am a bad white man I'm
bad Maya Maya May MO
okay keep going I I don't know what's
the product I don't know something dumb
is that I'm not as what's that logo not
very
sexist but in spite of that I think
these like American Eagle or something
women make great CEOs and great leaders
as well and yet only 5% of Fortune five
heart CEOs are women yeah so like what's
the evidence uh hold on like a lot I'm a
big fan of Maggie Thatcher but I don't
know who I don't I don't know okay I
don't even know what that is what's
mindspace you can't do that that could
be a totally fake company I don't know
no one's ever heard of that sounds like
their CEO is not very good because I've
never heard of their company I don't
know though maybe it's a male CEO who
knows right now go to expressvpn.com
YT using the internet without expressvpn
it's like having a first aid kit but not
keeping it stocked most of the time
you're probably fine but what happens
when you get a paper cut and you're out
of Band-Aids every time you connect to
an unencrypted Network in cafes hotels
or airports any hacker on the same
network can gain access to your personal
data such as your passwords and your
financial details doesn't take much
technical knowledge to hack someone just
some cheap Hardware is needed hackers
can make up to 1,000 bucks per person
selling personal info on the dark web
expressvpn creates a secure encrypted
tunnel between your device and the
internet so that hackers can't steal
your sensitive data it would take a
hacker with a supercomputer over a
billion years to get past expressvpn's
encryption I love how super easy it is
to use just click a button it's you fire
up the app it's on your phone it's on
your tablet it's on your laptop very
very easy right now go to expressvpn.com
YT
expressvpn.com m i h a e l letter y
letter T and you can get an extra 3
months for free expressvpn.com
[Music]
YT some workout here woman should be
gentle sorry I guess I'm not your
woman
no some fashion she should put me before
her friends some kind of fashion company
no
way I saw a Yamaha drum head is that
she's a
trophy why don't you bring her
[Music]
instead like a some kind of clothing
company I me
Porche that was like a vintage Porsche
no okay I'm still sticking with fash
create my own
future
huawe what like a Chinese spy telecoms
company Huawei what's really funny about
this is that the Chinese Communist Party
tries to Route out all this kind of woke
verbiage in in their own country but in
the other countries that they're now
colonizing in part through Technologies
like Huawei I guess they like to push it
CU they know it weakens countries this
is kind of a muscle right right here wow
amazing WWE I not in a million years
would I have guessed that next one next
one sit
down look the
camera this is what it looks like to be
exceptional to stand out from the crowd
to make
history but what if women didn't have to
be exception you blurred out the logo
huh what's that what's that what if they
didn't have to be the first it's going
to be something totally unrelated it's
going to be like crackers or something
only
woman what if being a female engineer
wasn't
remarkable what if women and men could
compete as equal I'm at least predicting
it's going to be a product totally
unrelated to the
commentary
I Don't Want To Make
History I don't want to be the only
woman I want to be one of
[Music]
many what's the
company Mercedes Mercedes why'd you cut
it off it doesn't even say it just
Mercedes be one of many that's fair
enough cuz Mercedes Mercedes it's a nice
car you know I've never owned one I I
drive cheaper cars they are one of many
right like if this were the really stand
out you're the only it'd be a McLaren or
something I want to be fairly impressive
but uh also well represented in
affluence suburbs that's what I aspire
to be Mercedes okay what 0 for three
it's pathetic absolutely PA I bet a
woman could have gotten them all women
are great they're perfect they they just
do everything perfectly and don't have
any flws or errors okay that's it I'll
try better next time see
[Music]
you